domingo enterana la policía
antidisturbio Sierra ni se dirige a la
Universidad sharif donde los estudiantes
protestan contra el gobierno un
manifestante ya detenido se encuentra
Atrapado en una moto entre dos agentes
uno de los cuales dispara la cámara con
lo que parece ser una pistola de pintura
en otro video en las proximidades de la
universidad los gritos de los
manifestantes que huyen se mezclan con
el sonido de los disparos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
las fuerzas de seguridad bloquean el
campo y si rodean a los estudiantes
mientras intentan escapar de un
aparcamiento
al mismo día en la universidad de ISSFAM
en el centro de Irán otra manifestación
estudiantes y ramíes rompen una puerta
de entrada y huyen de los que haces
lacrimógenos
el presidente del parlamento instó el
domingo a la policía a tratar con dures
a los manifestantes advirtiendo que el
movimiento pretende ahora derrocar el
régimen teocrático de Irán y que está
afectando al estatus Internacional del
país
nuestro enemigo estaba dispuesto a
levantar Muchas de sus sanciones Pero
estas protestas le han animado a
aumentar la presión sobre el pueblo
iraní
Estados Unidos impuso sanciones a los
dirigentes de las agencias
gubernamentales y iraníes y a la famosa
policía de la moral del país las
protestas comenzaron después de que la
policía de la moral detuviera y
supuestamente golpeara a masa mini de 22
años por llevar el pañuelo en la cabeza
de forma incorrecta a mini murió el 17
de septiembre mientras estaba bajo su
custodia la ong y era Newman Rights
afirma que más de 90 personas han muerto
y más de 1.500 han sido detenidas